if this time of year is about light and
warmth the new year for many may be more
about the struggle to keep it all
switched on
as gas prices continue to soar so too it
seems will energy bills and stress for
the families who must pay them you can
only pay out so much you know the wages
aren't going up covert kept karen
separate from much of her family this
christmas she has two part-time jobs but
relies on universal credit she says
she's already so worried about the bills
she's sometimes scared to put the
heating on no worries again on top of
all the other worries everything's going
up and so therefore it's going to have a
massive effect on me it will mean that
either we can't pay the rent
or we can't we what will definitely
happen we'll end up holding a lot of
money and obviously they come on at you
all the time that it's all got to be
clear by the end of the financial year
and all this that and the other
and if you haven't got it you just can't
do it
the off-gen price cap is in place to
protect consumers like her but it's
almost certain to rise again this spring
perhaps by as much as 800 or 900 pounds
a year and this is why the wholesale
price of gas is soaring to record highs
it's currently five times the average
it's been for the last decade
and for a country where gas is still the
single biggest energy source that means
consumers exposed
26 energy companies have already gone
under unable to balance these costs
against the cap
the industry says helping these
companies amounts to helping their
customers
the cost of supplier failure is actually
felt by every customer and that's
because significant sums of money
potentially around 100 pounds per
household per customer need to be
recovered to cover the costs that
suppliers incur when they pick up new
customers if government doesn't take
action i think we're going to see more
people falling into real poverty i think
we're likely to see that anyway if i'm
honest
that was the message the industry took
to the energy secretary today the
government has promised talks on this
will continue
but this is a global crisis caused not
just by a cold spell surge in demand but
supply shortages too that will take far
longer to fix
this is not a spike like it was last
winter and that's really because uh
we're at the start of the winter
december and we still have january and
february to go which are typically high
heating months so the demand is going to
remain high
but we have no new
supplies no news sources about to come
on stream
but in homes and businesses nationwide
those reasons will feel remote what will
matter is a hike in bills at a time
where the cost of living is already
spiraling the new year for many bringing
new worries to helen anne smith sky news